the idea of Fame and touring and putting
out music and seeing fans and being like
basically attacked on the street is
everything you thought it was gonna be
and yes and no I think you kind of like
put this idea in your brain of what you
want and then everything exceeds it by a
million percent usually it's the way
around usually imagination is better you
know you imagine something and you go
and you kind of go ah but you could
never possibly imagine this to go from a
place like Doncaster in the UK which is
so industrial so rundown so kind of
isolated feeling so misunderstood
feeling like I didn't belong anywhere
feeling like the the rest of my life was
gonna be a constant uphill mount and
struggle to simply be myself to get to
this place where we're in Toronto and
there's like being kids outside since
4:00 a.m. and this tour has been pretty
like crazy and dangerous and exciting
and all at once a just unfathomable man
you know I mean and I'm just fit so
close to them all can't believe I'm not
mad more yet what I don't know yeah what
I love about you too is that um you're
true to yourself and you treat yourself
in all ranges whether it's like non
gender conforming outfit yeah you know
we've seen you on on stage and dresses
we've seen you onstage in blokes we are
missing you and everything and you kind
of embrace that which is not something
we see every day off with every artist
that's out there was important for you
to represent that and to do that beam on
Jen container conform I just think I
just think I just simply labels and
labels for cereals or clothes you know I
mean I think I just want to be fluid in
every aspects of my life and just wear
what makes me feel comfortable or do
what makes me feel comfortable
I love whoever makes me feel comfortable
or look like whatever I want to look
like you know I mean I think in this
community this is what got so much
bigger than me you know I mean I think
even since the last time we spoke I was
just kind of starting and it was about
much more about what I thought and what
I was gonna do and what I saw about the
world and the feelings that I had
experience but it's about us now you
know I mean because they are 50% of what
young good is I want it to be a
community I want it to be a movement
because just similar because it is now
you know I mean I think they allow me to
express myself in a way that I allow
them to express themselves and it's so
funny it's not about anything over like
everyone talks about like I was he likes
having it and it record or what's it
like to to have a gold disc on and it's
like yeah that's cool and that's amazing
and whatever that's sick when you get it
cuz that's what you dreamed about when
you were 10 but the real power is me
looking at one of them and then looking
at me back and we have this mutual
sirens going on in our head this mutual
magic between us where we look each
other and go you save my life and you
make me feel like it's alright to be
myself that's what it's about about this
fanbase and I think that's why it's so
special can also be kind of cuz like
they knew the newbies called underrated
youth isn't also kind of terrifying
though that they are there to support
you and love you and accept you for
everything but then they also want to
know so much about you there's no
privacy they talk about you online
whether it's true or not yeah is that
how is that I mean I kind of stopped
looking to be honest I just think like
it is what it is money caught why invest
in some you can't control the things I
respond to or look I is whether it's
about someone's feeling trapped lost
alone scared I just don't really pay
into that rubbish because I think if you
go into that and you go into the dark
side
no I mean I think I just want to spread
positivity man I make people people feel
good about themselves because that's
what music does in it you know I mean
it's like ice for me it's gonna feel
good about myself when I was down you
know so I just kind of that'sthat's my
main priority if you like the new EP is
awesome I got here a little sneak peek
of it
aha me I'm so happy like it well I was
kind of nervous like because it's it's
different you know I mean it's it's a
different beast so for you I mean though
obviously the big track people are
talking about is the cloud with Dan yeah
man that was mad how did that come about
because Dan with imagine dragons huge
group always going how did that
collaboration Camaro just insanity right
we were on an another US tour like three
months ago and I was in New Orleans and
my phone rings am i I don't know can I
don't know about my yo hello and he's
like it's Dan Reynolds from as and
dragons I'm like yeah right whatever put
the phone down and it rings again he's
like it's actually done for my dragon
like wow and I pick up the phone and
he's just like yeah I love everything
you stand for because he's such a
massive activist in terms of being
yourself and with the lgbtq+ community
like he's such an advocate for making
people feel good and making people feel
wanted and accepted and he was just I
love what you doing I love that you kind
of I remember he said he was I love that
you're bringing young people back to
rock music and I was like wow that's
crazy to hear from the singer the
biggest one of the biggest rock bands in
the world you know I mean and he just
says we got to do something together and
I'm like okay done yes I would love that
I'd be amazing I will come anytime
and we just get in a studio and and I
saw him it leads and read in Festival
about five years ago as like a six like
17 18 year olds probably 16 17 and I
mean booked out and I was just like wow
and I was in a studio with him and we
have two mics side by side and I was
just
because your cool guy man when you meet
someone like famous everyone just like
yo man nice to meet ya you're good and
then I'm just freaking out next time
what I stands for imagine dragons like
that we're singing together and it's
crazy and I think that track was written
and produced in like five hours I think
you can tell yeah I mean it's got that
raw by and energy to it that's just like
come on man let's go you know I mean
yeah you said the EP is different and it
is different underrated youth like what
did you want to say with that title and
Whitin with the sound yeah man that that
was like this EP is kind of me talking
from my heart as I said earlier like the
first record was about my head and what
I thought but this EP is more emotional
because if the stories have heard man
and the people have met and how could I
not be touched in my soul you know I
mean we're doing this every day and the
I called it the under area VP because in
a world that kind of surrounds itself in
like song which one justified hey or
tells you to fall in line it tells you
it pressures your shoulders to to make
sure you you jump into one of the ten
boxes that there is the one common
denominator other people are me is like
the constant positivity the constant
optimism the constant strive for a
quality and ultimately the intelligence
is embedded inside our brains and
it's just truly incredible heceta you
know i mean and i go i know and we ain't
just bright kids talking about things
for attention we would genuinely want to
be a part of something amazing and as I
said called Andretti I saw this helpful
in relative because I think the future's
bright simply just cause we're in it you
know I mean yeah you recently said I
think it was - GQ about the karate you
know yeah I think I just think the age
of putting on a mask is over you just
got to look oh it's like Luis Capaldi
like Billy Eilish like like oh it's like
that point on a mask is over
authenticity is your biggest superpower
to be originally yourself is your
biggest superpower because everyone's
different and that's amazing you know I
mean don't hide that fact if you feel
like you hate what you see when you look
in the mirror listen to your favorite
artist if you feel like you can't tell
someone to do you love someone because
they do you think they're gonna feel
like it's wrong then that's just that's
just not right you are allowed to be to
look like to feel to love to have sex to
do your hair in any way that you
identify in any way that you see fit and
that's what's cool and that's what sick
like I look at someone with green hair
and a ball had a bald boss got green
hair and a big fat septum piercing in
Boots and mismatched clothes not as a
freak not as someone who belongs outside
the mediums of society today as someone
who is not afraid to express themselves
in a way that is right to them and
that's why I connect with my fans so
much because that's what I'm I had
always won